what's your bedroom better
it's just it's for the fan sam
i'm not asking
for myself
it's it's for all of i'll just throw
myself in with you guys
hooligans so what does my bedroom look
like yeah what kind of style of bedroom
do you have like what decor do you like
what's your bedroom look like a
big bed drew and big bed giant
big posts and no i i'm
candles
fire light
yeah soft music it's it's great you
should come on over and not a pair of
underwear inside never we burn it
you know all of us are hoping that
you're slightly serious
oh i'm serious
um okay um in this season of outlander
is it true that you asked an intimacy
coach
for
and if so what
yes it is true yeah okay why because
i'm like wait you guys have been
together for all these years you have
you must have rhythm for days right and
chemistry rhythm um
you know and i actually didn't even mean
that sensually speaking i'm trying not
to make any sort of innuendos here but
um that would be so inappropriate
no no an inter intimacy advisor you know
is kind of a more common practice now in
the industry when we started we were
totally green you know in your career
you've had to do similar stuff and as an
actor or actress you you're kind of just
thrown in the deep end and we were and
we sort of found our way through it
together and we've supported each other
through it but actually bringing someone
on board means we're all more supported
and we can we can find new ways to i
guess be more intimate and to to bring
add more to those scenes so i think it's
uh it's a really welcome addition it
sounds like people should bring them
into relationships let's just all get an
intimacy advisor right
what did you learn what can you teach us
you'll have to watch the show
[Music]
so smart so smart um
you're single uh wow why are you asking
well because i heard
for the human oh for the eulogies okay i
actually heard that you want to put
career ahead
and and put romance in the back seat is
that still true i never said that i
don't think drew barrymore but i i i
certainly you know the job is so all
encompassing and we spend so much time
on set and and it works so yeah but i'm
i'm open to something
i'm not sure what i'm saying i'm open
for but uh i'm open well i know we've
been talking about clothing with you
um one of the things uh that i was
curious about was um i heard that you
something with you in a batman costume
oh
yeah
well i don't just wear that to bed
no i i played i did a uh an arena tour
years ago now but um of batman live
which is basically like a sort of cirque
show
uh
meets batman and i played batman and
bruce wayne and i still have actually
the the cow from our batman so it's
pretty cool oh my god that's you oh god
yeah there we are
yeah
by the way i was in a batman movie you
you were i was you were in bed
oh my god
wow
oh my god that's fantastic
[Music]